they'll face 25-year-old right-hander
brady singer who's looking to bounce
back from a rough outing last time out
against the new york yankees
he struck him out
set him up with the fastball finished
him off with a slider good first inning
for brady singer beautiful job way to
get through it 11-3 on the season is
zach greinke he's been very good on the
road 107 strikeouts on the season
there's a line drive snared by a led
miss diaz and that is a quick one two
three inning for zach frankie once he
does and gets more comfortable he'll see
a big difference
well
that was a pretty snappy slider there
that strikes out oled miss diaz that's
right watch this baby oh yeah slider off
the plate there you go two strikes don't
give many cookies anymore
dozier cuts it
off and throws out mccormick a solid
second inning for brady singer
nice play by zach
gold glove winner
makes the play for out number two
on the ground right side yulia will take
it himself and grinky has three ground
ball outs in a one two three second he
is retired the first six we head to the
strike three call and that time hud a
little hesitation by brady singer as he
stepped back usually it's a fluid motion
but this time he stepped back and paused
right down the heart of the plate
four strikeouts for brady singer
in there wow
three strikeouts all looking
oh man beautiful he's got his rhythm
he's got his confidence
getting some runs
a little player in the right field is
going to parachute down in front of
jarrod dyson carlos correa hits the ball
the other way for a base hit that is the
first hit for either team in this game
beauty popped him up
salvi called off by ryan o'hearn
o'hara with the catch of grin back in
salvi
and zinger with four shutout innings
there's a ground ball up the middle
that'll find centerfield and the royals
have their first base runner
salvi though goes to the opposite field
lopez around second on his way to third
first and third for the royals with just
one out no score with one out in the
fourth lopez is at third salvi's at
first and here's carlos santana
up the middle base hit lopez scores the
royals take a one-nothing lead
all three hits hud either up the middle
or to the opposite field ding ding ding
that's exactly what you want to do
in there strike three call just lock
them up with that slider oh yeah that's
four strikeouts the last four all
looking they've never seen him before
that's a beautiful pitch especially up
in the zone they were expecting it down
singer 68 pitches it's been working
ahead of hitters better as this game's
gone along
but myers singles into right field
you can hear some of the friends and
family in the background cheering him on
with that two out base hit
and that is roll to first base o'haren
will take it himself the astros are done
in the fifth
we head to the bottom of number five
singer throwing very well fly to right
is first time up they over shift around
to the right form and he grounds one up
the middle and a base hit as o'hern
beats the shift
for the royals fourth hit fourth single
as long as total where he went deep into
a game gets that comebacker to correa
and even with dyson speed an easy turn
for granky to correa to uli guriel to
end the fifth innings
hey a little punch shot over the head of
whit merrifield astros in business with
a leadoff base runner they haven't had a
runner reach second base since the first
inning
caught by o'hearn and he'll double up
altuve
oh man
watch out boy that's a really big pick
me up right there
[Music]
correa hammers one deep to center taylor
is back and makes the catch
michael a plus taylor
taking a hit away from carlos correa
oh that's great hitting that's why i was
a little surprised hud that they shifted
for nikki lopez i have not seen many
teams shift for him they usually play
nicki straight up
lopez goes pitch taken
throw by maldonado skips away and nikki
lopez now 14 for 14 stealing bases this
year
popped up shallow center
jose altuve deep
puts it away for the final out of the
inning i'll see if he's having the best
night
this one slowly hit towards the middle
mary field tough play and yuli safe
there we go julie guriel snaps an 0 for
16
as he beats out an infield hit up the
middle
chaz lines one into center field that'll
be down for a hit back to back base hits
for the astros
that's yuli and chaz mccormick with base
hits and that'll bring up jake myers
nope
through him the slider and he misses the
bases will be loaded with two outs mark
team maldonado do up and he'll be called
back the astros are going to go to a
pinch hitter here with jason castro
hard hit base hit by castro into right
center field two runs will score
chaz mccormick crosses the plate the
astros lead this game
jason castro off the bench with a big
two rbi single then brings on domingo
topia his job get out the always tough
jose altuve
too short
they get the force
but
castro comes through
houston now with a 2-1 lead
here's the one-two then attendee swings
and hits it well to left field brantley
is back he's still back he's at the
track and it's going to be off the wall
benetendi jogs into second base
with a leadoff double back come the
royals with a runner at second base and
nobody out and here's hunter dozier oh
there's a drive
deep to left field that one is long gone
hunter dozier so much for watering the
opposite field garden
why don't you just pick out a cookie and
hit one a mile give your team not only
the time but the lead
sharply hit on a 100 mile an hour
fastball and correa has a single in the
left field correa a two-hit knight
tonight has five hits in this series
and he needles the outside corner at 97
miles an hour
get out the paintbrush outfield shallow
and towards left center
fallen there for
him it does yeah buddy
he'll take that jam shot any day of the
week
oh and then he came far
inside and hits perez
that one moves lopez into scoring
position
on the ground to altuve to correa for
one carlos with the throw for the double
play kendall graven gets a huge double
play to get through the eight
there's a line drive base hit to left
field
the rookies chaz mccormick and jake
myers contribute here in the ninth
inning down one with back-to-back line
drive singles all right just one more
battering wouldn't you know one of the
best
hitters they got jose altuve
base hit left field
mccormick coming around the throw to the
plate
got
unloaded
a cannon shot from left field
you could tell by the way ben and tindy
charge that ball he says man i got to
save our guys here game over royals have
taken the first three games of the
series against the first place houston
astros
you